Let's continue coding
our content provider.
query() will be the most complex
of the required content provider methods.
We begin with the bones
of the query() operation.
We use our sURIMatcher object
once again to switch on the type of URI.
This is the only function
where we will have to fill out
every type of URI in the content provider,
as several of them are used
for querying only.
We'll implement the basic
Weather query first.
For this query,
we just pass through
all of the parameters to the database.
Pretty simple stuff.
Let's fix these parameters
so they make some sense.
"strings" here is actually a projection;
S is a selection,
the next array is selectionArgs.
And the last string is sort order.
That matches a lot better.
At the bottom of the function,
we're going to set the NotificationURI
for our cursor
to the one that was passed
into the function.
This causes the cursor
to register a content observer
to watch for changes that happen
to that URI and any of its descendents.
By descendants, I mean any URI
that begins with this path.
But, we still need to test this.